claude castonguay a été un acteur majeur
de la révolution tranquille au début des
années soixante sept actuaires travaille
à la conception du régime des rentes du
québec
puis il copréside la commission qui
proposera au régime public d'assurance
maladie
il y aura transformation du des
ministères de la santé et du ministère
de la famille
élu en 1960 disputé libéral de louis
hébert
il devient ministre de la santé et des
affaires sociales et implantent la loi
créant la régie de l'assurance maladie
elle fixe le mode de rémunération des
médecins et offre des soins gratuits
pour tous
trois ans plus tard claude castonguay
quitte la politique
il passe à l'emploi du groupe financier
la laurentienne dont il deviendra le pdg
mais il contribue au débat public en
participant au comité du non au
référendum de 1980 puis convaincu que le
canada devrait reconnaître la différence
québécoise
il mobilise les gens d'affaires pour
l'accord du lac meech
après l'échec de l'accord il est nommé
sénateur conservateur par le premier
ministre polonais mais deux ans plus
tard en 1992
devant l'incapacité de faire évoluer le
dossier constitutionnel
il démissionne tout en étant prêt à
faire certains compromis et la
conception du pays
netapp à salles
retenu dix ans par la majorité à la
demande du gouvernement québécois il
s'attaque ensuite à une révision du
système de santé
quitte à renier le principe d soit
universel le québec n'en a plus les
moyens selon lui en 2008 il explique ses
conclusions mais évidemment pas question
de près du hat iv notre système de santé
nous proposons plutôt un rôle
complémentaire pour le secteur privé
afin d'en faire un allié du 7 du système
public
puis il s'attelle à un autre dossier il
s'inquiète de l'avenir des régimes de
retraite et en 2011 il publie une autre
étude
quand on voit qu'à peu près deux tiers
des travailleurs qui ne sont pas
couverts la part des régimes d'employeur
s'en vont vers la retraite avec des
moyens qui ne leur permettront pas de
maintenir leur niveau de ville
il propose alors que les travailleurs
paient une cotisation pour créer une
sorte de régime d'épargne-retraite
obligatoire jusqu'à la fin de sa vie la
vie de claude castonguay sera sollicité
il ne se gênera pas pour exprimer ses
opinions dans ses mémoires en 2005 et se
définira comme un révolutionnaire
tranquille je ne me rase la radio canada
montréal